John Stamos and wife Caitlin dish on
bringing their son Billy to Walt Disney
World
it's fun eats he caught up with the
Disney loving duo at the Mary Poppins
Returns premiere in Los Angeles where
they opened up about their first trip
with their little one to the happiest
place on earth
yeah we're going to Disney World
tomorrow I'm hosting the candlelight
procession there so it's like full-on
you know Disney we're taking our son for
the first time yes and we have a lot of
Disney pounds ready explain what it
doesn't sound it's like regular adult
clothing but different colors that
represent Disney characters so you might
see some of those this weekend with our
whole family said let's wait a year two
years until he's a little old enough to
but it's already seven months and what
are you gonna dress him up as he's got
literally every costume Under the Sun
and his suitcases been packed for over a
week so pretty much everything that he
can dress up as he will be dressing up
what brings you here after all this time
same thing that brought me the first
time and I've come to look after the
banks children oh yes you too
[Music]
I watched it this is exciting I mean you
know this you know the purpose the
promos have made us cry you know it's
pretty interesting we just put extra
tissues in my bags John and Kaitlin also
joked about their first holiday season
as parents we're hosting and I'm stoked
I can't wait to decorate the house once
we get back from Disney World all the
decorations are going up he's good we're
just gonna dress him as the little elf
on the shelf and leave him there for
till New Year's